c'est l'un des opéras les plus joués au
monde c'est l'une des oeuvres les plus
emblématiques de mozart autour de la
flûte enchantée pendant près d'un an
choristes solistes lycéens apprentis
enseignants ont travaillé main dans la
main autour du même projet celui de
monter un opéra qui s'adresse à tous
pour le coeur de la fabrique opéra la
difficulté ça n'est pas de chanter mais
de savoir déchiffrer un livre est écrit
en allemand en 1791 ou un tapis dante
sur le 11 et l'autre sur le guet
c'est difficile allemand un peu oui ça
fait longtemps que je n'ai pas pratiqué
depuis ma terminale
je crois oui donc ça fait cinq ans et du
coup elle se remet dedans en allemand ça
pique un peu j'ai fait deux années
d'allemands quand j'étais à l'école il
ya bien longtemps mais comme je suis
anglaise j'ai pas trop de problèmes avec
la laissons déjà après pour le pour
l'avoir parker je pense que ça va être
compliqué non non non non en haletant
pour les 70 choristes ce jour là ça
n'était que leur deuxième répétition pas
de professionnels dans les rangs que des
hommes et des femmes qui adore chante
ok ce que vous pouvez vous défendre les
sopranes nous sommes à quatre mois du
jour j tout reste à faire
l'allemand s'est pas une langue que tous
les choristes ont l'habitude de
pratiquer donc les accents toniques
d'une langue ils sont écrits en
adéquation avec la musique et la musique
sonne bien quand le texte et bien
prononcé on va commencer par le tour de
taille à quelques mètres du coeur dans
une autre salle de classe du lycée paul
gauguin on enchaîne me demander de gros
grains clé placer tous les choristes se
sont invités à se présenter pour la
prise de mesures
j'ai toujours non droit qu'est dessous
donc là je tombe sur 103 100 en 3 pour
la deuxième année consécutive ce sont
les élèves de la section couture qui
seront chargés de la fabrication des
costumes marienne pourquoi c'est
important que les élèves participent à
cette aventure parce que c'est une
fabrication réels c'est à dire que moi
j'aime beaucoup quand il ya des demandes
extérieures et qu'il y ait une réalité
du terrain de l'épaule fabriquer
participer à un opéra c'est un plus sur
un cv et de nouveaux choix possible pour
l'orientation entre une classe où il ya
pas de projet et une classe où justement
il ya ce projet là ils ont envie de
venir
tout simplement ces dons l'envi l'envi
et ça ouvre sa les autres vers
orientations du coup ça comment dire ça
ça les motive
à vouloir continuer et non s'arrêter
seulement un bac pro les costumes mais
aussi le maquillage et la coiffure
confier à d'autres jeunes tous élèves au
centre de formation des apprentis
leur mission embellir chaque
protagoniste de la fabrique opéra pour
le maquillage il va falloir apprendre à
forcer le trait j'essaye de faire un des
grains des plus loin de prune pour le
personnage de papageno pourquoi tu as
choisi cette couleur là parce que sa
principale couleurs au niveau de sa robe
c'est la couleur prune donc faire un
petit rappel au niveau des yeux forme
être plus que d'habitude c'est c'est
quoi cette technique non pas forcément
c'est le coin externe c'est ce qu'ils
voient le plus donc comme on nous
demande de faire assez voyant ce soit de
loin de près mais du coup le premier
c'est une très belle couleur quand on
est tout en haut du zénith
il faut qu'on reçoive l'émotion du
personnage de la même façon que
lorsqu'on est au troisième rang et donc
le maquillage lui il est travaillé pour
un espace théâtral où chacun va va le
recevoir donc le maquillage forcément il
est plus appuyé il est plus lumineux il
ya un vrai travail qui va finir en
quelque sorte le personnage j'en ai vu
ce soir là jean claude cotillard est
venu rencontrer ses petites mains sans
qui rien ne serait possible
alors pour bien se faire comprendre rien
de tel qu'une petite explication de
texte papa gana et c'est vrai qu'il faut
c'est vraiment la petite je le décris
tout à l'heure mais là la fille
pétillante ces pétillants c'est
sympathique c'est voilà les ailes et
c'est la bonne copine papageno vous êtes
tous une bonne copine dans nos
entourages
c'est celle qui sont sympas à sap à
naples où on a pu chanter
chez les coiffeuses aussi on s'entraîne
le soir après les cours entre arabesques
et longueur de cheveux il faut déjà tout
prévoir pour anne laure c'est une
deuxième participation à la fabrique
opéra donc l'originalité elle est là
elle est bonne mais il faut surtout
penser au temps tu dois mettre à ta
créativité mais en la matière que tu va
disposer ce jour là le metteur en scène
n'a pas donné de consignes particulières
être juste créatif élégant mais c'est
plus une expérience personnelle prix et
pourquoi tu as besoin de cette
expérience personnelle bas parce que
j'aime bien ça m'évade c'est on est
libre en fête
mais jean claude cotillard il vous donne
quand même des contraintes oui mais
c'est pas pareil c'est qu'on reste quand
même enfin bon ils nous donnent des
contraintes que ce soit comment dire ce
soit quelque chose de chic de classe
mais après au niveau il nous donne pas
des volumes précis ya pas des choses qui
sont imposés sur la coiffure sur les
ornements des choses comme ça c'est doux
c'est complètement différent en fait est
une aventure de cette ampleur là je
pense qu'il ya pas beaucoup de jeunes
qui ont la chance de pouvoir y
participer
donc déjà on quand je leur propose je
vais pas dire que je dispose 2 mais je
leur fais bien comprendre que ce serait
bien regrettable de ne pas le faire
l'année dernière le cas échéant
quelques-uns n'ont pas voulu parce que
se sont imaginé passer que des épingles
voir des petits travaux et là cette
année m'ont carrément demandé moi cette
année je veux participer ce quand elles
ont vu les autres en retour elles se
sont rencontrées du compte qu'elles ont
loupé une superbe expérience
ça c'est quelque chose à cet âge là
c'est pas à louper quoi c'est une
habituée de la flûte enchantée
après marseille budapest elle interprète
le rôle de la reine de la nuit pour la
troisième fois mais c'est une première
au sein de la fabrique opéra
sarr plus j'adore c'est un rôle qui est
fort qui musicalement dramatiquement
même si a pas beaucoup de pub beaucoup
d'interventions mais ils vont à la salle
qui quitteraient for trade ce jour là
les solistes on répète avec jean claude
petit attention parce que tu perds la
tragédie là là on est dans le mélodrame
ta mère ne peux plus te protéger la dre
a trahi ni ta mère ne peut plus tard
protéger c'est toujours très profonde
très puissance y'a pas à discuter la
mort de ton père mon pouvoir 7 et 1 sur
le metteur en scène est exigeant il ne
veut pas seulement des voix wazemmes à
dire que le chant c'est le moment on n'a
plus d'autre dialogue possible donc on
n'a plus qu'à ouvrir le corps et quand
on ouvre le corps la musique en sort
c'est ça l'opéra
que dois-je faire je confié à moi l'an
dernier à l'interpréter michaela dans
carmen cette année elle joue pamina un
nouveau rôle clé et un nouveau challenge
j'ai beaucoup de chance je suis très
contente très très contente de pouvoir
chanter ce rôle est un rôle du
répertoire bas que tout soprano rêve de
chanter je pense à ce coin là oui c'est
vraiment un très beau rôle de la flûte
enchantée des chasses et c'est une
merveille d'opéra on ne serait ce pas
allez partout y compris dans des lieux
où l'opéra n'a pas vraiment sa place
comme ici au centre pénitentiaire de
sarran derrière ces murs vive 730
détenus des hommes et des femmes
condamnés ou prévenus
ce jour là alors qu'istres de léonie au
grand complet vient donner quelques
extrait de la flûte enchantée
on
à quelques mètres d'eux lors qu est une
trentaine de détenus des hommes et des
femmes tous volontaires pour venir
écouter mozart
j'écoutais musique classique en fermant
les yeux et en fermant les yeux ça me
permet d'échapper ça me permet de en
fait de rêver et puis de respirer aussi
la musique est importante
pourquoi parce que c'est un lieu
difficile la prison toute façon quand on
est enfermé c'est forcément difficile
pour qui que ce soit quelles que soient
les raisons quel que soit le pourquoi il
commet donc lancé un moment mais
forcément dans une difficulté parce
qu'on est loin de ses proches on est
loin de ce qu'on aime on doit les coupés
du monde quelque part comme c'est
forcément c'est là où la musique
intervient
positivement parce qu'elle nous permet
de nous apporter un peu d'oxygène aussi
et ça c'est quand vous avez vous la
répétition aurait pu s'arrêter là mais
clément joubert est un chef d'orchestre
partageur comment ça fonctionne ça si
jamais vous voulez aller plus vite ils
vont plus vite si vous voulez aller plus
lentement
on va s'endormir mais vous pouvez aux
détenus qui le souhaitaient il aura
laissé sa place
être pédagogue cfl s'est fait refaire
les choses aux gens c'est laisser faire
et donc ça bien important de montrer que
la musique ça se partage la musique c
c'est quelque chose d'actifs c'est c'est
un partage d'émotions mais un partage
2-2 regard un partage 2 2 personnes
le détenu a été excellent dans son
nouveau rôle il s'est même beaucoup
amusé
ça fait quoi d'être j'aime d'orchestre
quelques instants romance et ses
merveilles s'émerveille j'ai
l'impression dès lors c'est ils
l'expliquent là mais cela ne suffit pas
d celui qui aura fait cgt 13 mai croit
très content un moment d'écouté un
moment d'échangé entre musiciens et
détenus certains ont même pu essayer les
instruments qu'il est plus fort quand on
a fait l'expérience l'année dernière
c'était un peu effrayant savais pas trop
comment ça va se passer dans quel
endroit on allait arriver et finalement
une fois dans le gymnase c'est vraiment
une salle de répétition comme les autres
c'est pas plus intimidant que qu'autre
chose et puis et pouvoir discuter avec
eux
on sent que voilà ça amène quelque chose
et il ya un vrai échange
c'est pas que dans un sens ils nous
donnent aussi leur impression là ils ont
essayé les instruments cela ils ont
envie de participer
c'est sympa et pendant ce temps le coeur
s'activent
après le chant place à la mise en scène
le groupe doit savoir chanter mais aussi
savoir se mouvoir sur une scène et selon
que l'on soit un homme ou une femme
ça n'est pas tout à fait la même chose
ce qui est important c'est que le corps
avancent et les pieds viennent soutenir
simplement ça à sentir que la colonne
vertébrale désire aller et que à ce
moment là les pieds viennent porter le
corps ça c'est la note technique et sur
cette note technique vous rajouter ce
que vient de dire avant pour les hommes
la certitude de la puissance et du désir
nous sommes les hommes on se le rappelle
voilà et pour les femmes un peu plus je
dirais de de sensualité quelque part si
la mise en scène est une nouveauté côté
voit le coeur a presque trouvé ses
marques
plus de volumes plus de confiance et
puis l'allemand est désormais beaucoup
mieux maîtriser
on y est presque mais encore peu de
chose pour le par coeur et sait
indispensable puisque maintenant
aujourd'hui il ya toute la mise en scène
qui se met en place
ça veut dire qu'il faut avoir
suffisamment intégré le texte de façon à
ce qu'on puisse bouger reprendre
n'importe où être dans n'importe quelle
position courir en chantant en allemand
être en train de sortir de scène ou de
voilà faut être prêt à tout c'est très
agréable
voilà on est tous dans l'énergie voilà
je crois
on attendait ça avec impatience voilà on
a fait quelques répétitions musicales et
puis c'était voilà ce matin savait qu'on
allait vraiment entrer dans le vif du
sujet on n'est pas déçu je crois
dernière ligne droite direction le
zénith cette fois où chaque choriste
chaque soliste va se faire maquiller
coiffer costumés à deux jours de la
générale dans les coulisses le stress
monte entre plaisir et appréhension
comment est-ce qu'on se sent comme sa
hache et -3 avec une hâte fold d'avoir
la salle remplie
en fait et d'être à la première c'est la
wii non c'est la 6 et les muses
excellent moment ça fait combien ça fait
trois mois qu'on travaille là-dessus on
travaille pour ça là pour être ici et
pour avoir le public en face et après un
an de travail
les voilà sur scène moment d'émotion
presque de communion quand arrive la
reine de la nuit
pendant 2h45 les voies vont s'enchaîner
belle alchimie entre les professionnels
et les amateurs
cette année encore l' aventure humaine a
parfaitement fonctionné
2 après mise et après mozart la fabrique
opéra se lancera un nouveau défi en 2017
et ce sera avec verdi